Irina masenga is the
135th person to walk into this cholera
treatment center today
it's run by the charity Doctors Without
Borders in a camp for displaced people
near the city of Goma
Irina can barely walk or talk
infections start with chronic diarrhea
and if untreated can end with death
it's already killed eight people in the
camp children are the most vulnerable
three children are infected
I saw that my children started vomiting
and became very weak when we brought
them here we found out they were
suffering from cholera they're still
very weak
the treatment is simple and effective if
it's provided in time
most patients only need rehydration and
can recover within days
all of these tents are full of patience
and Doctors Without Borders says it's
putting up more as the number of cases
rapidly Rises the outbreak is extremely
serious we've seen a growing number of
kisses in the past days we're now
averaging over 150 cases each day and
the numbers continue to mount both here
in this Camp the Lango and also across
the road in lucidala bolango Camp is
home to about 100
000 people who've fled the M23 armed
group as it seized territory from
Congo's government forces in recent
months
m23s widely understood to be backed by
neighboring Rwanda but Rwanda denies it
many of the people here say they ran
away when m23s Fighters executed men and
raped women in their villages in masisi
territory
M23 denies committing atrocities in
spite of the mounting evidence entire
communities fled and are now struggling
to get by in unsanitary conditions
it's raining almost every day here at
the moment the ground is wet and sudden
the camps cramped the shelters are
squeezed close together and this is one
of few toilet facilities here there's
only one toilet for around every 500
people
spraying disinfectant can help to
prevent infections but the Medics say
the cholera outbreak won't be stopped
until the sanitation is improved
there's not nearly enough clean water
for drinking cooking and washing
humanitarian agencies have installed
some Taps but it's only about a fifth of
what's needed for the rapidly growing
population here back at the treatment
center doctors say they expect everyone
here to survive others who fled to new
camps that don't have medical facilities
may not
it's a Health crisis that can easily be
ended if only there's enough help but
one that would never have happened if
people here hadn't been forced from
their homes
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera bulengo
Democratic Republic of Congo